[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau bat année
d'interdire emmanuel macron et angela
merkel se sont entretenus avant-hier par
visio conférence est ont annoncé un plan
de 500 milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie européenne mais les 25 autres
états membres l'approuveront t-il et que
penser du rôle de la banque centrale
européenne depuis le début de l'épidémie
et du rôle des institutions européennes
l'europe en sortira-t-elle plus forte ou
plus fragiles pour débattre de toutes
ces questions nous recevons aujourd'hui
frédéric farah qui était que de myst
vous enseignez à la sorbonne vous êtes
chercheur au laboratoire phare de la
sorbonne vous êtes l'auteur d'une
introduction inquiète à la macroéconomie
et la sortie de votre prochaine ouvrage
sextape sur l'impuissance organisé de
l'état français a été repoussée au 27
août
frédéric sarre a pour lutter contre le
coc vite 19 ans n'a pas hésité à
confiner la population et à mettre des
secteurs entiers de l'économie à l'arrêt
ce qui ne s'était jamais vu dans
l'histoire
à tel point qu'on nous promet une crise
de 29 doublée d'une crise financière
type 2008 et d'une crise de la dette
est-ce qu'on a une chose de s'en sortir
avant même de parler de 500 milliards
d'euros de relance est-ce qu'on a une
chance de s'en sortir on a une chance de
s'en sortir si tout d'abord on reconnaît
que la crise à la fois affecte aussi
bien l'offre que la demande et pas
uniquement l'offre ont la chance de s'en
sortir
si on abandonne toute une série de dogme
assez vite et assez tôt c'est-à-dire à
être innovant en matière de politique
économique nous en discuterons sur la
manière dont la politique monétaire peut
être conduite sur la manière dont la
politique budgétaire peut être conduit
et d'abandonner absolument une obsession
qui est celle des déficits et des têtes
parce que c'est pas le moment
vu l'ampleur du choc comme je disais
d'offre et de demande si effectivement
on est innovant en termes de politique
économique
on abandonne les dom du passé on sait
inventer de la coopération au niveau
international au niveau européen mais de
manière vraiment en rompant avec le
passé très largement et on abandonne une
idée de revenir très vite à on va dire
au monde d'avant c'est à dire comme on
l'avait fait lors de la crise de 2008
au départ on avait accepté un peu de
relance et à partir de 2000
11 on a abandonné sa très vite et on est
revenu à l'austérité est ce qui a
entraîné un replongeons de l'économie
européenne donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
pour s'en sortir
c'est moins lié à une situation même si
elle est très brutal que liées aux
moyens qu'on va employer parce qu'il
faut pas oublier quand même que nous
sommes un continent incroyablement riche
malgré la crise malgré tout ce qui peut
nous arriver et que les moyens les
hommes les compétences sont au rendez
vous la question est de savoir est-ce
qu'on va savoir utiliser les ponts
levier politique est-ce qu'on va savoir
inventer les coopérations qu'il faut est
ce qu'on va pouvoir agir assez vite et
ne pas s'engluer dans toute sorte de
compromis que l'on peut faire qui sont
parfois complètement raté si on
rassemble ces conditions même si ça va
être d'une grande violence
je pense qu'on a les moyens de s'en
sortir si on est dans la demi-mesure on
les timides on essaye de faire du
rafistolage d'ici de là et bien ou un
retour à l'austérité trop tôt trop vite
quand on entend par exemple sur le maire
dira va falloir faire des efforts et
tout de suite on est dans cette musique
là effectivement les chances de s'en
sortir risque d'être beaucoup plus
réduite pour ne pas dire carrément
disparaître
donc là on est dans l'étape 1 on n'est
qu'au début de la crise on n'a pas vu
toute l'ampleur c'est maintenant qu'il
va falloir agir et pas en comme on dit
au tennis faire petit bras c'est à dire
vraiment être dans des actions ample que
ce soit budgétaire que ce soit monétaire
que ce soit fiscale et sortir des
sentiers battus c'est la seule condition
ce sont les seules conditions pour s'en
sortir est vraiment avoir bien à
l'esprit qu'on est à la fois dans un
choc d'offre
ça affecte les entreprises mais aussi de
pouvoir d'achat la consommation les
ménages et qu'on se retrouve dans ce
double mouvement donc à ce moment là il
va falloir agir et il ne pas se poser la
question sur des points de déficit en
plus sur des points de dette en plus ce
n'est vraiment plus ni le moment ni la
question je je je pense que pour moi
c'est clair nathalie jenson vous êtes
économiste professeur associé à neoma
business school intervenante à sciences
po même question
es tu attends une chance de s'en sortir
je pense qu'on est oui les hommes ont
des ressources insoupçonnables donc je
ne suis pas tout à fait pessimiste quant
à la sortie
évidemment j'aurais pas vraiment les
mêmes recommandations fortes que mon
collègue donc j'irai beaucoup plus sur
le fait qu de surtout laisser la
capacité de rebond justement et de
l'initiative privée pour pouvoir faire
face à cette situation inédite bien
évidemment il n'y a pas de précédent
puisque ça a été on peut même pas
comparer à des situations de guerre
puisque là ça a été une mise à l'arrêt
ordonné par l'état pour effectivement
préserver et éviter que le virus s'est
diffuse d'avantagé et génère un coût
social élevé donc on est dans un cas en
fait quasiment d'externalités et de
justification de l'intervention de
l'état
même pour tous ceux qui ne seraient pas
favorables est en effet le premier effet
est sûr c'est un choc d'offre et ils
gagnent toutes les conséquences que ça
peut avoir ensuite sur la
désorganisation de l'économie
et puis avec la progression la lente
progression vers la fin du confinement
bien évidemment on a une reprise
d'activité économique qui ne sera pas
immédiate et qui va donc générer une
réorganisation importante mais si on
laisse cette réorganisation se faire il
n'y a pas de raison pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de rebond puisqu'on va tout
simplement s'adapter à un nouveau
contexte
alors commençons par ce plan de 500
milliards d'euros de relance annoncées
par angela merkel et emmanuel macron il
s'agit au fond de lever une dette
commune sur les marchés une laisse une
dette commune à aux 27 états membres de
l'europe alors est ce que c'est une
bonne idée d'intelligence ont alors une
bonne idée ça fait longtemps que toute
façon cette idée d'avoir un un vrai
budget
comme il peut y en avoir au niveau des
états nations c'est ça fait longtemps
que cette question à traîne puisque ça
faisait un obstacle éventuellement à ce
que la la zone monétaire de l'européenne
puisse fonctionner de façon optimale
puis il y avait jusqu'à maintenant pas
de transfert de budgets de transfert
comme on peut en avoir dans un état
lorsqu'un au niveau national un état de
va pas bien il est en état de récession
et que il va pouvoir organiser des
transferts en termes mêmes de région et
bien en fait cette possibilité là au
niveau de l'europe n'existait pas en
dehors des programmes structurels ce qui
n'a rien à voir avec des problèmes en
fait conjoncturel c'est à dire de juste
lié aux circonstances
donc jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait que
des bons budget structurelles qui venait
aider des pays qui devait procéder à
certaines réformes de structure mais pas
de budget pour faire face effectivement
des budgets pour pouvoir transférer deux
aux états qui en ont besoin donc de ce
point de vue là en effet on a une on a
un point qui a été gagné par rapport à
cette idée qu'il faudrait que l'europe
se dote d'un vrai budget d'un vrai
budget qu'ils fassent pas pour faire
face à des situations justement de
récession économique
comme on peut la voir actuellement alors
l'ironie veut que ce budget il va
finalement être sans doute voter alors
la mise en place en tout cas de ce
budget de relance va se produire à un
moment où on fait finalement c'est une
crise qui concerne tous les pays
puissent qu'en général on a besoin de
ceux de ce budget d'ajustement de
transfert lorsqu'on fait face les pays
qui font qu'ils font partie de la même
zone monétaire font face à des pas des
chocs qu'on appelle asymétrique
c'est-à-dire que certains sont en
récession pendant que d'autres vont bien
et bien ici finalement on va arriver à
avoir un budget de relance dans un
contexte où en fait toute la zone euro
fait face à une situation de crise et on
va le mettre en place
effectivement pour pouvoir faire en
sorte qu'ils aillent aider
les états les plus en difficulté et
effectivement c'est donc dès lors du
transfert
et là ce sera donc la comité européenne
qui pourra lever les fonds avec les pays
qui seront donc tous pour emprunteurs à
hauteur de de leur poids économique dans
la zone
et si j'ai bien compris ce sera l'union
européenne qui remboursera sur son
budget c'est ça frédéric farre alors les
choses si vous voulez soit un petit peu
plus complexe en quelque sorte par
effectivement juste un mot qui fait écho
à votre question précédente
et quand vous regardez sur cette
initiative et je vais vous répondre très
précisément à votre question vous vous
rendez sur le site de l'elysée et vous
regardez la déclaration qui a suivi
l'intervention du maquereau et madame
merkel et vous y trouvez ça que ce plan
en question un jeu je cite très l'elysée
un plan de relance de remboursement qui
sera contraignant donc effectivement
donc il est dit que il est demandé aux
états de contribuer dans ces 10 noir sur
blanc sur le site et il est dit
clairement je cite encore ces
déclarations un engagement clair que les
états membres doivent prendre appliquer
des politiques d'économie que mon
tiersen et un programme de réformes
ambitieux donc c'est à dire que quand
vous allez sur le site de l'elysée vous
vous vous lisez ça je n'invente pas donc
vous voyez que healy à cette espèce de
flottement sur l'idée d'un remboursement
contraignant c'est écrit c'est
l'adjectif qui est employé sais c'est
pas moi qui le fabrique
c'est écrit noir sur blanc tout le monde
peut aller vérifier je n'invente
strictement rien donc ça veut dire que
il y aura une partie peut être des fonds
qui seront dix à fonds perdus c'est à
dire on demandera pas de remboursement
et s'essayer l'union européenne qui en
quelque sorte va éponger parce que
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
histoire l'union européenne n'a pas de
capacité fiscale elle même de lever
impliqué ce qui va se passer c'est la
commission qui va se rendre sur les
marchés financiers et qui va
effectivement lever des fonds
c'est ça qui se passe c'est s'ils
voulaient donc et ensuite ça va pas être
redonnée aux états directement ces fonds
vont être ciblées sur des secteurs des
régions c'est pas on va dire tiens
l'italie vous voulez 50 milliards voilà
50 milliards pour l'italie voilà 60
milliards pour je ne sais qui tu donc
non c'est à dire qu'il va falloir cible
est fléché en fonction des secteurs et
qui vont être concernés et ça va être
aussi en fonction des régions qui ont
été les plus touchées par par la sphère
du coc vide
économiquement parlant donc ça c'est
très important donc en quelque sorte
dans cette histoire le grand débat et il
a aujourd'hui sont intervenus les pays
du nord dit les faucons on voit par
exemple l'autriche qui dit ah non on
veut pas des fonds et des ce type de
mécanisme à fonds perdus c'est à dire
qu'une partie en quelque sorte les états
n'auraient pas à rembourser
il faut que ça soit que sous forme de
prêts et ils ne sont pas d'accord
puisque pour que ce plan existe un jour
il suffit pas que madame merkel et
monsieur mâcon disent oui il va falloir
que tous disent oui et s'il suffit que
certains disent non fin de l'histoire
et là on retrouve votre question de tout
à l'heure est-ce qu'on va s'en sortir ou
pas
si effectivement même des mesures parce
que 500 milliards salaire beaucoup mais
quand vous allez les ventiler sur
plusieurs pays ça fait pas tant que ça
donc si déjà pour des mesures qui
peuvent paraître un petit peu inédite et
bien eu en tant que tel vous voyez déjà
des réticences le temps qu'on va perdre
donc la question est ce qu'on va s'en
sortir ou pas est-ce qu'on va pas perdre
du temps sur ces questions est ce qu'on
rembourse on rembourse pas est-ce que
c'est à fonds perdus c'est pas à fonds
perdus et le temps qu'on mette en place
toute la mécanique financière trenec
farah pardon de vous interrompre mais
c'est fondamental ces questions là ils
sont importantes
on peut se mettre à la place du jeune
chancelier autrichien sébastien geurts
on va voir son visage parce qu'il est
très peu connu il a 33 ans il est à la
tête de l'autriche l'autriche c'est
probablement le pays européen qui s'est
le mieux sorti de la crise du cornet
virus c'est là où il ya le moins de
morts
millions d'habitants ils sont ils ont
seulement 630 non ils ont aidé économie
florissante
la suède qui a pas l'air d'être tout à
fait d'accord non plus avec ce plan elle
elle n'a pas pratiqué le court
physiquement alors les suédois se sont
confinés de même ils n'ont pas arrêté
leurs économies et on leur demande
maintenant de payer les pots cassés de
ceux qui ont confiné qui ont paniqué qui
n'avaient pas de tests etc etc on peut
se dire que l'effet timo il renâcle un
peu d'intelligence on oui je voulais
juste revenir sur l'idée de du
remboursement en tout cas un gala merkel
lorsqu'elle elle à l'issue de la réunion
avec emmanuel mâcon elle c'est sur ce
point qu'elle a insisté sur le fait que
le le prêt qui sera évidemment la somme
d'argent qui sera levé par la commission
européenne avec les états qui seront
donc à hauteur de leurs de leur poids
économique dans ceux pressés c'est donc
eux qui rembourseront si vous voulez ce
prêt à hauteur de ce qu'ils représentent
économiquement au niveau de la zone euro
et bien ce prêt est remboursé par contre
la façon dont s'est attribué au spa
entre les différents pays c'est à dire
elle a effectivement cessé sous forme de
subventions crtc la transfert versée
c'est le budget européen qui va
transférer de l'argent à certains états
mais c'est pas l'état qui va rembourser
cet argent directement ce sont les états
qui vont eux remboursés
elle a la cote part qu'ils auront dans
le titre émis si vous voulez par la
commission européenne
même si ça a l'air un peu compliqué
comme ça c'est pas si compliqué mais
voilà le remboursement il se fait à ce
niveau là il se fait pas au niveau de la
somme d'argent serre que s'il l'europe
décide d'allouer je ne sais pas moi 70
milliards à l'italie l'italie ne va pas
les rembourser et 70 milliards ce
qu'elle va rembourser c'est la
quote-part qu'elle aura dans les saintes
dans l'est dans les 500 milliards levés
oui voilà
est ce que la question j'ai envie de
poser c'est est-ce que là il n'y a pas
on voit bien qu'il ya certains états
membres qui ne veulent pas être
solidaires mais est-ce qu'on peut
accuser l'union européenne elle même ne
pas être solidaire
il me semble que l'union européenne là
c'est montrer plus solidaires en tout
cas à des velléités de solidarité dont
elle n'avait jamais fait preuve jusqu'à
présent en tout cas pas à ce point il ya
des états qui freine on l'a dit il ya
l'autriche il ya le ya le la suède il ya
les pays bas et le danemark
mais l'union européenne elle l'europe
elle elle est solidaire non frédéric
farre à écouter le problème ça pose la
question du statut de l'union européenne
l'union pérenne
avant tous coopération interétatique
avant toute chose même si l'union
européenne c'est une affaire hybride un
jeu c'est juste c'est remarques avant de
rentrer dans les détails
pourquoi c'est quelque chose d'hybride
parce que l'union européenne ces trois
légitimité qui marchent ensemble et qui
sont plus ou moins fonctionne plus ou
moins bien ensemble concurrentiel vous
avez une légitimité fédéral c'est la
commission européenne vous avez une
légitimité populaire c'est le parlement
et vous avez une légitimité
intergouvernementale c'est le concept
est donc le problème c'est que dans le
dernier traité dit de lisbonne les trois
légitimité sont renforcés sans qu'on
sache laquelle doit prévaloir et
laquelle doit tommy si pour répondre à
votre question est ce que l'union
européenne ait fait preuve de solidarité
alors j'ai envie à l'union européenne ce
et qui alors si on va prendre ce qui
représente l'intérêt commun l'union
européenne c'est la commission puisque
la commission par les traités elles
portent l'intérêt général de l'union
donc on va dire c'est sa composante
fédérale
donc at elle fait au départ au d elle
elle va lever va dire qu'elle va
réallouer des fonds structurels au début
de la crise de l'ordre de 37 milliards
première chose qu'elle fait donc ça
reste modeste deuxième chose elle dit on
va lever les règles budgétaires les
règles budgétaires on pourrait dire
c'est sympathique
bravo en abandonne les pailles le pacte
de stabilité 3% 60%
on abandonne ce qu'est ce que c'est 3%
les trois versants 3% de déficit 60% de
dette et si vous voulez y ait un pacte
de stabilité première génération qui
était celui 96 97
et puis ensuite il y en a un deuxième
génération qui est né du traité sur la
coopération la gouvernance qui a été
renforcée après 2012 c'est tous les
paquets ne pas rentrer un détail tupac
six pack semestre européen qui sont un
pacte de stabilité on va dire version
renforcée ou plus avancé que le premier
bon mais vous avez à dire que c'est 3%
et 60%
dieu sait si on a dit du mal de ses
critères dix critères de maastricht
il aurait été levé tout de suite oui ils
ont été levés mais on peut regarder ça
autrement en disant très bien bravo il
ils ont levé mais en fait ça voulait
dire quoi sabler dire à chaque état bah
on a levé la faire maintenant à vous
brouillés mais à vous de vous
débrouiller ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'effectivement les états vont
aller sur les marchés financiers pour
effectivement bas et mettre les actions
les obligations dont ils ont besoin mais
selon la situation des états et bien
qu'est ce qui va se passer
certains pourraient vu la situation
avoir des taux d'intérêt moins favorable
que d'autres
c'est là qu'à ce moment là ce que
j'appelle la solidarité par défaut la
solidarité par défaut c'est de dire je
lève les règles débrouillez-vous la
solidarité veut pas que le plan de 500
milliards levés par la commission c'est
pour te fasses problème là avant ça y
est tout le débat est ce qu'on utilise
le mécanisme européen de stabilité
il ya eu vous souvenez la réunion de
l'eurogroupe
est-ce que ça va être une utilisation de
ce mécanisme sous forme de
conditionnalité ou pas de
conditionnalité et à l'issue de la
réunion de l'eurogroupe
quand on relit la déclaration de rome on
avait dit pas de conditionnalité pour la
dépense sanitaires et le temps de la
crise ensuite est arrivé
la réunion du conseil qui a suivi juste
après pour entériner ou non ces mesures
et on s'est rendu compte que bon ont
validé ce qui a été choisi par leur
groupe et mon avis dit donnant mission à
la commission de réfléchir sur un plan
dit recovery fund pour essayer de
relancer la fin et donc c'est là
qu'arrive dans ce temps-là l'initiative
merkel macron mais ils en sont friands
de 500 me la met juste je veux faire
juste et très marquée ne pas être trop
long mais par exemple quand on a évoqué
le mécanisme européen de stabilité on a
entendu d'ici de la acquis à 700
milliards là dedans qu'il faut mobiliser
on a commencé à évoquer des sommes
incroyables
moi je pose juste la question parce que
oui mais ça revient à votre question
qu'est ce que c'est que l'union
européenne d'où vient cet argent du
mécanisme européen de stabilité
il vient du fait que lorsqu'on a créé ce
truc en 2012 il y avait ce qu'on appelle
les fonds appelable ils font appelable
c'est quoi ces fonds 2013-2014 que les
états en fonction
c'est ce que disait ma collègue de l'un
de leur parent de leur poids économique
ont contribué à cette affaire donc ainsi
par exemple l'italie a contribué à 18 8%
à la naissance de ce n est celle qui a
contribué à ça et les pays bas par
exemple à 5,5 donc d'une certaine façon
d'où vient l'argent du ms il vient au
départ des états et ensuite qu'est ce
que fait ce véhicule financier il prend
cet argent va sur les marchés financiers
et essaye de créer ce qu'on appelle des
effets de levier pour ensuite reprêter à
nouveau cet argent aux états vous voyez
un peu le circuit c'est au départ ce
truc
il existe quand les états à mettre de
l'argent dedans une fois que l'argent
est dedans
ce mécanisme l'acquis et qui est basée
au luxembourg et bien va sur les marchés
financiers élevés des sous vous voyez
que derrière ce qu'on appelle l'union
européenne
la logique étatique est toujours à
l'oeuvre et c'est pour ça que je dis
pour répondre à votre question il faut
regarder ce qu'a fait la commission
puisque juridiquement elle incarne
l'intérêt commun puisque c'est ça la
mission de la commission européenne
c'est d'incarner l'intérêt
donc moi je trouve qu'au départ on a été
un peu frileux et puis au fur et à
mesure où on s'est rendu compte que la
bce ne ferait pas tout où elle même ne
pourrait pas faire toujours le job comme
on lui demande il faut trouver une
solution mais si on voulait vraiment
faire du fédéralisme type à l'américaine
par exemple c'est pas un pour cent que
le budget européen devrait être parce
que c'est un pour cent des pib
additionnés il devrait être grosso modo
au tour de jean % mais si on dit on
passe de 1 à 20 ça voudrait dire que les
états par exemple les plus gros comme
l'allemagne ou voit une partie de son
propre pib qu'ils soient mobilisés ou
prélevé pour faire naître un véritable
revenaient un véritable budget européen
conséquent de nature fédérale
je ne suis pas sûr que les allemands et
on peut ne pas leur reprocher d'ailleurs
souhaite voir une partie de leurs
propres richesses basculer dans le pot
commun pour ce fédéralisme parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est que le fédéralisme
en un mot concrètement c'est pas juste
des montants d'argent qui vont ici de là
ça voudrait dire que demain par exemple
sur les fiches de paye on prélève une
cotisation de x ou un impôt de y qui
irait dans une caisse commune par
exemple pour financer la retraite des
lettons pour financer la retraite des
portugais ce serait ça concrètement le
le fédéral c'est à dire ce serait
vraiment une solidarité entre personnes
c'est pas juste des montants monétaire
qui passe d'ici de là mais ça voudrait
dire que en quelque sorte on va
mutualiser mais super forme de transfert
significative des choses importantes
parce que pour l'instant la seule
communauté de redistribution et de
solidarité qui existe à ce jour
opérationnel c'est au niveau national
c'est pas au niveau européen peut-être
que ça demain ça existe il centralise
européen mais c'est pas le cas
sans aller jusqu au fédéralisme
frédéric farre à allaire d'appeler de
ses voeux véritable fédéralisme
économique
revenons à ce qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui ce que vous êtes d'accord
nathalie jenson oui oui de toute façon
pour le moment où on est on est juste
dans une phase initiale comme je disais
tout à l'heure on est dans la phase très
très de d'avoir un budget un peu plus
qui à plus d'ambition que le budget
existant comme lé là l'a rappelé
frédéric féral c'est à dire que pour le
moment ils représentent très peu il
représente juste entre 1 et 2 % du
budget des de la zone européenne
et là on veut effectivement le faire
passer avoir une dimension un peu plus
importante avec cette idée de transfert
donc effectivement quand on est dans un
pays il ya des transferts parce que
c'est le rôle de l'état par rapport aux
missions de l'état que ce pays a décidé
voilà de ceux de se doter
ça voudrait dire qu'on fasse le même
travail au niveau européen donc et cela
implique également qu'on a des pays
européens qui ont des des objectifs ou
des philosophies en fait de deux de
dépenses publiques qui vont donc être
des préférences similaires c'est bien ça
que ça implique
et c'est bien tout le problème parce
qu'on n'est pas vraiment certain que les
pays européens ont ces mêmes préférences
puisque ils n'ont pas a priori
lorsqu'on regarde ce qu'ils font au
niveau national si vous voulez on n'a
pas l'impression qu'ils ont utilisé la
même façon de dépenser dépenser leur
argent
et c'est aussi ce qui constitue un point
de blocage pour aller plus loin donc si
vous vous laissez pas parler par
l'expérience
on voit bien que les préférences
fiscales et de dépenses budgétaires des
pays on va dire plutôt du nord ne sont
pas les mêmes que les préférences
fiscales et de dépenses budgétaires des
pays du sud est en effet site 1up un
obstacle un peu difficile à affranchir
puisque tant qu'on n'a pas une réunion
des préférences dr tant qu'on n'a pas
une certaine harmonie de ses préférences
on voit mal comment on pourra faire
fonctionner un vrai budget au niveau
européen au même titre que le donc à
passer un vrai une vraie étape de
fédéralistes parce que pour avoir un
fédéral
il faut quand même avoir une objectif
commun en tout cas une vision commune de
ce que doit être l'état et de comment il
doit fonctionner dans la zone qu'il
couvre or aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'impression qu'on a atteint ce niveau
en europe
et là on voit quand même ce qui s'est
produit avec l'initiative merkel macron
qu'il ya quand même on voit les la
solidarité néanmoins puisque d'ailleurs
en gala merkel est assez cohérentes avec
ce qu'elle a dit depuis le début puisque
si on reprend même s'est dit discours
avant ces initiatives au moment où
effectivement en discuter d'une
éventuelle partie de mes une éventuelle
utilisation du mécanisme européen
on avait elle a toujours dit qu'en fait
pour elle la solution qu'elle
privilégiait serait passerait par le par
le budget de la communauté européenne
est donc de ce point de vue là elle est
assez cohérente depuis le début et mais
non et on voit bien qu'elle est quand
même animé de cette idée qu'on ne vit
une situation exceptionnelle et qui à ce
titre là doit aussi avoir une initiative
européenne pour faire face à cette à
cette situation inédite qui touche tous
les pays et par conséquent qui
légitiment une action de la part de la
communauté européenne
alors on a bien compris que c'est pas
forcément demain que les transferts
sociaux vont s'opérer des pays du nord
vers hippie du sud et que les les
habitants de l'allemagne vont payer les
retraites des lettons ou d où des
portugais néanmoins là un pas a été
franchi
alors est-ce que ce pas wawrinka blement
être franchie est-ce que les 27 pays
vont être d'accord on continue d'en
parler juste après une pause
[Musique]
le virus agit plus sur les poumons sur
le cerveau si j'ai bien compris et donc
ça me paraît difficile d'imaginer un
monde totalement différent la pandémie
va pas avoir changé fondamentalement les
règles du jeu et les règles de la vie
quotidienne selon patrick artus la crise
du collègue 19 pourrait sonner le glas
du capitalisme néolibéral c'est un choc
exogène c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé de l'extérieur il traduit pas une
défaillance du système économique
capitaliste mondialisé marocaine vivant
le virus a servi de catalyseur
mais les problèmes étaient déjà là les
problèmes de gilet jaune ça date pas de
du virus
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
gata ce trop fine il ya un tournant mais
on re se remet à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort là la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec deux
économistes frédéric farah et nathalie
jenson comment sortir de la crise que
nous avons nous mêmes créé de toutes
pièces en confinant la grande majorité
de la population européenne les 27 états
membres vont ils se montrés solidaires
les uns envers les autres et notamment
envers les états les plus touchés et que
de mick mans où les plus fragiles le
rôle de la banque centrale européenne
elle a assoupli sa politique monétaire
fait que farrah depuis le début de de
l'épidémie oui alors de toutes les
façons madame lagarde s'est inscrite
dans les pas de son prédécesseur c'est à
dire que est là comment dire qu'on tue
et le les programmes n'est que son
prédécesseur pu mettre en oeuvre mais
c'est important de revenir un petit peu
dans la chronologie de cette affaire au
départ madame lagarde est intervenue et
dans sa première intervention qui lui a
été reprochée en disant que l'afld une
carafe qu'il était maladroite l'autre
pour moi il n'en est rien où elle avait
dit qu'il n'appartenait pas à la banque
centrale européenne de s'assurer qu'il
n'y ait pas d écart parce qu'on appelle
l'écart de spread de taux d'intérêt sur
les marchés des obligations en matière
de dette publique donc en gros elle
disait ma vocation c'est pas de faire
par feu s'il y avait des écarts en
termes de taux et certains ont dû ramer
matin me lagarde qu'est ce qu'elle dit
elle dit des bêtises mais elle ne fait
pas son boulot et au et après comme elle
a engagé ce programme d'urgence à
hauteur de 750 milliards certain andy a
enfin elle revient à la raison
ouf elle a bien compris en fait et je ne
crois qu'il n'en est rien c'est à dire
madame lagarde n'est pas quelqu'un de
bête est loin de là elle sait ce qu'elle
dit simplement elle se faisait le porte
parole de la position des faucons
c'est-à-dire dessous du nord qui en
quelque sorte disait ben non la bce bon
déjà monsieur draghi
elle s'est affranchie de pas mal de
dogme bon sa mission est pas celle ci
est ensuite effectivement qu'est ce
qu'on a vu on a vu sur le marché
obligataire particulièrement pour la
dette italienne que l'étau commencé à
remonter
donc on s'est dit attention une panique
et qui a commencé à paniquer c'est nous
parce que je rappelle que des têtes
france les banques françaises soient
exposées à hauteur de 400 milliards par
rapport à la dette italienne
donc il était très malvenues
qu'effectivement eux
eh bien ça s'emballe pour les italiens
parce que ça allait nous revenir dessus
donc effectivement il y a du avoir
effectivement négociations moi je ne
suis pas dans les couloirs de tout ça et
résultat des courses c'est bien madame
lagarde est revenue à la charge en
disant qu'effectivement bas elle va
intervenir de manière massive et elle va
faire encore plus si nécessaire
mais en fait la bce ne peut pas tout
même si elle innove en matière monétaire
parce que ça pose la question de l'art
l'organisation de la politique
économique c'est-à-dire au pilier
monétaire il faut un pilier budget et
parce que la monnaie ne fera pas tout
sauf que comme le piler budgétaire on en
parle depuis tout à l'heure
ben il a encombré soit dans un budget
européen insuffisant soit dans des plans
plus ou moins bien monté et bien
évidemment tous les regards se portent
sur la banque centrale européenne parce
que elle est encore une fois une
composante fédérale dans l'histoire
puisque c'est une monnaie qui est mise
en commun pour 19
donc est ce que par rapport toujours à
votre première question est ce qu'on va
s'en sortir si effectivement la banque
centrale européenne est la seule qui
agit qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
peut-être elle va éviter une nouvelle
crise de la dette peut-être
effectivement elle va permettre à ce que
les banques et les liquidités
nécessaires mais est-ce qu'elle va
suffire à elle même de relancer
l'économie de recréer de l'emploi n'en
suis pas sûr après il peut y avoir
encore de nouvelles mesures encore plus
original en matière monétaire qui
peuvent être mises en place
mais je crois que la banque centrale
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle ne relance
pas l'économie européenne même à
l'époque de monsieur draghi
ce qu'elle a fait c'est qu'elles
limitent la casse elle permet une
stabilité économique et financière
mais il faut bien comprendre qu avant
même la crise du coc vide
à aucun moment depuis l'après 2012
la zone euro a atteint des niveaux de
croissance incroyable elle était
florissante et autres elle n'a jamais
montré un visage d'un dynamisme
exceptionnel c'est pour ça que quand
arrive la cuisse du coc vide elle
n'arrive pas dans une zone qui était en
pleine surchauffe
loin de là qui étaient rencontrèrent qui
commençait d'ailleurs à décélérer
économiquement donc c'est pourquoi je
dis madame lagarde se retrouve dans une
position où elle va reprendre peut-être
en amplifiant les mesures de son
prédécesseur il faut voir là
effectivement les mesures alors ça
entraînera techniques bancaires qui
effectivement sont des mesures qui se
veulent encore un peu plus radicale
mais est-ce que ça va suffire tout seul
pour pouvoir relancer la dynamique
européenne et nous sortir de cette
situation
à titre personnel ça peut être
d'excellents pare feu ça peut limiter la
casse mais ça ne suffira pas n'at-elle
gens sont alors on entend ici et là
partout à peu près alors l'union
européenne n'a rien fait les
institutions européennes n'ont rien fait
la banque centrale européenne elle a
fait est ce qu'elle a bien fait oh oui
pour le en tout cas et elle l'a fait de
façon massive je ne sais pas si elle a
bien fait parce que toute façon face à
une icône à une crise de l'an de cette
ampleur il est compliqué quand on a
quand on est une banque centrale de
faire dans dans le dans la finesse donc
effectivement elle y va on a pu lire çà
et là le titre de la politique monétaire
bazooka puisque elle est là elle a sorti
tout de suite
750 milliards comme première enveloppe
alors effectivement pas comparer à sont
à son collègue américain on peut dire
que elle fait moins ou en tout cas
qu'elle n'a pas annoncé tout de suite
qu'elle ferait de façon illimitée
puisque effectivement ce n'était pas
dans ses propos mais elle elle fait
effectivement quand même de façon
similaire c'est à dire qu'elle va bien
acheter de la dette à la fois publiques
et privées faut pas l'oublier elle
achète aussi beaucoup de dettes privées
sans doute plus
ça a été le cas dans les dents les mois
fin dans les programmes prêts dans le
programme précédent
mais puisque ici on a bien comme un choc
de l'offre au départ on a bien un gros
problème de dette privée puisque les
entreprises n'ayant plus de 2 de revenus
elles sont donc confrontés à un problème
de non seulement de liquidités mais très
vite de solvabilité puisque si si elles
n'ont pas d'activité elles ne peuvent
pas rester comme ça pour toujours en
activité et là effectivement on voit
bien le point délicat de l'action
monétaire c'est que effectivement elle
va traiter de façon relativement
homogène bien évidemment en choisissant
des titres mais on va on va dire qu'elle
va choisir
par catégories de titres et elle n'aura
elle ne va pas les regarder les
entreprises c'est à dire que dans une
situation comme on a aujourd'hui bien
évidemment des entreprises ont fait
faillite parce qu'il ya des entreprises
plus fragile que d'autres mais dans une
politique de cette mesure on va en fait
assisté l'ensemble des secteurs donc on
va pas aller on va pas discriminer entre
celles qui auraient pu qui aurait dû
faire faillite
parce qu'effectivement de toute façon
elle n'était pas bien géré et donc la
crise est un simplement un révélateur et
celles qui en fait et qui ment à qui on
prête et qui vont pouvoir survivre grâce
en fait assez à ces aides
supplémentaires
donc ça c'est en fait la limite de
l'action de la politique monétaire c'est
à dire qu'elle a une portée générale et
elle va pour essayer de maintenir à flot
une économie en termes de valorisation
on va dire mais c'est pas ça qui va
effectivement comme l'a dit précédemment
frédéric si c'est pas ça qui va porter
qui va en fait déboucher vers une
reprise économiques de la reprise
économique elle va venir le jour on va
reprendre de la vraie activité
économique qui va générer des produits
des ventes des recettes de l'emploi donc
là la banque centrale elle ne fait que
soutenir des valeurs qui normalement
devraient être moindres puisque on a une
baisse d'activité donc théoriquement la
valeur des entreprises valent moins
lient leur dette va vouloir moins
puisqu'elle elles ne peuvent pas
rembourser pour le moment l'idée les
dettes courantes étant donné qu' il n'y
a aucune entre
en tout cas pour certaines en plus si on
rajoute à la difficulté de ceux de ce
bilan c'est que vous avez toute
l'économie n'est pas non plus à la règle
il ya une partie de l'économie qui n'est
pas à l'arrêt et qui elle fait plutôt
face à un boom
donc on pensera à toutes les activités
essentielles qui sont restées ouvertes
et puis à toutes les activités qui comme
le secteur de des produits d'hygiène qui
ont redoublé effectivement de chiffre
d'affaires parce que on a un besoin
accru dans dans ce type de produits donc
on voit bien que l'action de la banque
centrale effectivement elle est massive
elle est bien là elle vient bien en
appui
mais elle ne sera pas du tout suffisante
et pour ce qui est de la disposition à
faire plus j'ai plutôt l'impression que
dans les déclarations qui ont été faites
par rapport au programme exceptionnel
qui a été adopté donc le programme de
pour là pour faire face à la pandémie
l'aller le conseil des gouverneurs se
réserve quand même le droit de remettre
en cause les contraintes imposées par
les statuts c'est écrit alors je ne
dépends en français donc je ne vais pas
vous le lire mais en d'autres termes il
est quand même on peut quand même
interprété en filigrane le fait que les
contraintes imposées donc on pense tout
de suite aux contraintes en termes de
rachat date de titres en fonction donc
quand on parle quand on prend les titres
publics les titres donc émis par les
états
et effectivement la banque centrale elle
achète en fonction de la quote-part de
l'état dans le capital de la bce
donc ça veut dire que l la bce va
pouvoir acheter à hauteur de 18 et
quelque chose pour cent des titres
allemands parce que c'est s'il a la cote
que la quote-part de l'allemagne dans le
capital de la bce
elle achètera pour environ 14 % ceux de
la france pour la même raison
donc elle elle suit ce qu'on appelle la
clé de répartition et pour le moment
c'est pour ça qu'elle dit qu'elle
qu'elle continue à quand même respecter
son mandat puisque pour le moment elle
continue à acheter les titres en
fonction de cette clé de répartition
donc la question en fait qui peut fâcher
dans le futur c'est ce sera celle là
et c'est pour ça qu'elle avait rappelé
christine lagarde à cette occasion
qu'elle n'a joué elle n'agirait pas sur
les sprays parce qu en d'autres termes
ce qu'elle disait c'est qu'elle n'irait
pas acheter plus de titres italiens
parce qu'ils sont plus nombreux pour en
fait contrebalancer le fait que si l on
achète pas plus eh bien les taux
pourraient remonter
voilà donc c'est ici que c'est pour ça
qu'elle avait donc la question qui fâche
elle est sur la clé de répartition
d'hachette ses actifs la solidarité donc
entre les 27 états membres va-t-elle
fonctionner avec ce plan de 500
milliards dont on a parlé on sait que
l'autriche et son jeune chancelier sont
plutôt contre il suffit que un pays ne
soit pas d'accord et il n'y a plus de
plan de 500 milliards
frédéric fabre oui je voulais juste
faire réagir à ce que je viens en temps
oui parce que qu'est ce que révèle cette
clé la répartition juste une chose qu
encore une fois qu'est ce que c'est que
l'union européenne derrière tout ça
derrière la banque centrale s'est encore
des états donc on voit bien que c'est
selon le le poids qu'ils ont et bien
effectivement leur place le rôle là
comptez donc on voit bien que derrière
des mots c'est que je dis il faut
toujours garder à l'esprit que c'est une
institution internet mais c'était juste
une parenthèse mais à chaque fois ça
revient vous avez vu à chaque fois
qu'est ce qui se cache des atouts saba
c'est les banques nationales des
différents états avec leur quote-part
c'est les contribution étatique c'est
toujours la même c'est la même affaire
donc ça veut dire que quand on dit que
les l'europe ne s'est pas montrée
solidaire c'est faux ce sont les états
membres qui ne se sont pas montrés
solidaires je crois qu'en fait il faut
bien comprendre les choses
il y à certains états qui ont su par
leur poids économique que par leur sens
diplomatique pas le rapport de force
qu'ils ont su créer faire en sorte que
des orientations de l'union européenne
aille dans leur sens l'euro disons le
même s'il est moins aujourd'hui c'était
un marc déguisés les la manière
d'envisager ou de penser le budget ça
fait écho à ce qu'on appelle
l'ordolibéralisme allemand
si vous voulez la manière le fait que la
bundesbank se trouve pas à lisbonne et
se trouvait à francfort c'est pas parce
que francfort c'est plus joli que
lisbonne c'est parce qu'effectivement
quand on a créé l'euro bac lt la
puissance monétaire c'était l'allemagne
pourquoi on a mis à la tête de la bce le
premier c'était un néerlandais pourquoi
on a mis un néerlandais parce que le
florin qui était la monnaie des pays bas
avait abdiqué pour le marque depuis
belle lurette donc forcément on a mis un
candidat qui va dans cette direction
donc qu'est ce que révèlent les choses
c'est pas qui est des intérêts nationaux
c'est pas un problème qui les
internationaux c'est de savoir qu'ils
aient fait prévaloir comment les fait
prévaloir l'allemagne
comment tirer effectivement a fait
prévaloir très largement les siens en
faisant de sorte que l'euro lui soit
largement profitable
effectivement ensuite elle a mangé son
chapeau à partir de 2012 quand
effectivement monsieur draghi
effectivement a commencé à se sortir de
l'orthodoxie allemande bon et donc à ce
moment là on a dit ou qu'est ce qui se
passe et où l'inquiétude sur laquelle on
reviendra du tribunal allemand et aux
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que d'une certaine façon
quand vous regardez pas ans à la tête du
mécanisme européen de stabilité
c'est un allemand quand effectivement et
à quoi on assiste en europe c'est un
déclin de la france depuis très dans les
postes clés dans l'orientation et même
si monsieur macron et ses multiples
multiplier ses discours dans tous les
sens depuis son arrivée on a vu que ça
fait pour faire un clin d'oeil à
monsieur jacques chirac cheat bon et
souvent cheat d'ailleurs donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que effectivement
c'est quelque chose d'hybride l'union
millions européenne est fait et c'est
évident que on voit bien que un état
comme l'autriche ou demain un autre état
peut au nom de la règle d'unanimité tout
bloquer la question est de savoir c'est
pas est ce qu'il existe des intérêts
nationaux par il en existe et c'est pas
un problème
c est ce qu on sait les défendre oui ou
non aux espions c'est faire valoir ses
propres intérêts dans cette affaire
bon aujourd'hui effectivement vous voyez
quand il ya une décision de la commente
ire de la cour allemande
tout le monde s'inquiète en se disant
tiens c'est l'allemagne
il ya une décision qui est prise là bas
qu'est ce qui va se passer et ce gang de
karlsruhe et là que la cour de karlsruhe
exactement alors que on sait très bien
que si c'est une décision du conseil
constitutionnel sur cette affaire il se
passera rien du tout parce que le
conseil constitutionnel va bien jouer le
jeu des règles européennes telles
qu'elles ont été dictées acceptés par
les uns par les autres
donc en fait si vous voulez il faut être
je crois qu'il faut une cure de lucidité
sortir d'une naïveté
il ya une somme d'intérêts qui jouent et
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un par exemple
c'est comme ça qu'on dit le projet
européen
on appelle ça tout le temps j'aimerais
bien savoir qu'est ce qu'on met derrière
ça et souvent mais ça derrière ça de
manière négative en disant pourquoi il
faut être ensemble
il faut être ensemble parce que comment
va concurrencer la chine ou comment on
va faire face aux états unis c'est très
curieux d'imaginer une association
d'état par la négative c'est à dire
pourquoi on va être ensemble pour faire
face à d'autres
mais pourquoi on est ensemble mais
positivement donc si vous voulez c'est
pour cela que je peux t'y cette question
il faut l'éclaircir une fois pour toutes
et finalement que les autrichiens n'ai
pas envie ou et a un goût pour la
solidarité qui n'est pas le même je
tirais saisit pas dire que les
autrichiens c'est les mauvais du film
ils défendent leurs intérêts ou ils
pensent être les leurs la question est
de savoir est ce que les italiens les
portugais les français aussi souci de
leur intérêt est ce qu'on peut trouver
un compromis entre les deux je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une question de
rapport de force et penser que parce
qu'on négocie jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
avec des cernes sous les yeux
y a pas de rapport de force 6 raconter
une belle histoire je pense qu'ils en à
la question certains essayent de faire
valoir leurs intérêts les britanniques
on peut penser ce qu'on voudra du brésil
sont partis parce qu'il pensait que
c'était leur intérêt de partir les
allemands et c'est de faire en sorte que
la combine l'orientation européenne
aille dans leur sens les pays du nord
font la même chose
nous les français on a un gros problème
c'est qu'on a pensé qu'en renonçant à
notre souveraineté on gagnerait plus d'
influence à la fin on n'a pas
d'influencé ou moins et la souveraineté
elle refuse donc le problème c'est pas
tellement les autres c'est nous qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour faire valoir nos
propres intérêts mais ça c'est la
chanson oui de toute façon les il est
clair que le l'union européenne
et la zone monétaire européenne elle a
été adoptée par ce que certains des pays
notamment l'allemagne a bien voulu
concéder parce que sinon elle ne serait
pas venu qui si elle avait dû renoncer à
tous ces principes donc c'est pour ça
elle a bien accepté l'euro parce que
effectivement comme l'a rappelé frédéric
de toute façon l'euro c'était parce
qu'on ne voulait pas adopter le
deutschmark pour l'ensemble des pays
européens
donc on a deux on a donc créé cet euro
parce que c'était pas politiquement
correct de dire que le deutschmark
allaient circuler dans les pays
européens mais elle allait être cette
monnaie européenne qui de fait était
avant avant l'euro est d'ailleurs c'est
c'est drôle puisque ce quand on regarde
le pouvoir représenté par l'euro on
s'aperçoit qu'il est pas plus que le
poids du deutsche mark
avant l'euro donc voilà il ouvrit une
preuve elle est bien là et bien
évidemment l'allemagne a bien voulu
faveur s'ils voulaient bien changé le
nom de sa monnaie pour pour faire plus
politiquement correct mais elle ne
voulait pas changer ce qui la gestion
monétaire et budgétaire qui allait avec
le type de monnaie qu'elle a toujours
voulu préserver
depuis donc depuis cette fameuse crise
donc des années 30
donc là est la question elle est
effectivement là
il a été bien poésie je pense par par
frédéric auparavant c'est à dire que si
on vient on est venu tous pour des
raisons différentes haut niveau dans la
zone européenne
et le problème c'est qu'à un moment
donné et bien il faut tenir compte des
réalités et il faut savoir pourquoi on
est venu et si on effectivement en
france venus pour avoir retrouvé du
pouvoir et bien effectivement la
mauvaise nouvelle pour nous c'est qu'en
fait on en n'a pas retrouvé et
effectivement on a plutôt eu un abandon
de souveraineté sur plusieurs questions
mais je dirais que c'est abandon de
souveraineté de toute façon au niveau
monétaire on l'avait déjà de fait parce
que quand vous faites partie d'un
système le système monétaire européen
avant l'euro de toute façon on n'a pas
non plus beaucoup de souveraineté sur sa
politique monétaire quand on veut rester
dans un système de taux de change fixe
avec le reste des autres pays second
corner ça je dirais que c'est pas le
c'est pas la bande aux plus grands je
vous interromps parce qu'il nous reste
quelques minutes et y ait de la question
que j'aimerais vous poser
quid de la france que ce pacte de 2 500
milliards d'euros soit adoptée par la
totalité des états membres ou pas le
gouvernement français depuis le début du
confinement a fait des chèques d'échec
des chèques d'échec
il ya on est plutôt dans une période de
récession il y aura moins de rentrées
fiscales pour l'état français
encore une fois la question c'est est ce
qu'on peut s'en sortir
est-ce qu'on peut comme comme on l'a
fait là dire aux entreprises on vous
soutient on est là qu est ce qui va se
passer
écoutez qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est
cesser fin à mon avis en ce moment vu
que le secteur privé dans cette
situation que l'on connaît
et bien les deux mois de confinement si
on suit une étude wells et eu bat il ya
120 milliards de pib qui est parti en
fumée
bon effectivement l'état aujourd'hui
doit absolument continuer même si ça
coûte très cher ces mécanismes à la fois
pour amortir et aussi pour relancer
mécanisme pour amortir c'est à dire par
exemple toutes les mesures liées au
chômage qui sont effectivement chômage
partiel bon donc ça c'est extrêmement
important l'état doit en quelque sorte
même s'il le faut devenir en quelque
sorte un payeur en dernier ressort c'est
à dire il doit presque vraiment assurée
ce qui est nécessaire presque même les
salaires 1
donc c'est absolument nécessaire pour
qu'il n'y ait pas comme je disais au
tout début notre intervention
christophe crise de demande choc de choc
de demande il doit intervenir
hélas aujourd'hui la question n'est pas
de savoir si on va être à 10% 12%
déficit ou quoi que ce soit la question
ce n'est pas je le répète un niveau de
dette qu'on est con et 115 120 125 130
la question c'est pas le niveau parce
qu'il ya pas de consensus dans la
science économique pour dire si on
dépasse 90 ça va pas s'ils ont fait 80
c'est mieux outre la question est de
savoir comment finances
pour l'instant notre moyen de
financement c'est ça passe par les
marchés financiers est aujourd'hui notre
dette comment elle se ventile la manière
suivante 20% de notre dette est à la
banque de france au titre de la banque
centrale européenne on a à peu près 25%
qui sont dans nos banques et leur s et
des investisseurs étrangers
donc eux qui détiennent c'était donc la
question est de savoir est ce que
aujourd'hui on arrive à la financer oui
on arrive à la finance et pour pas grand
chose
oui est ce qu'elle nous coûte moins cher
qui est un autre des oui encore une fois
aujourd'hui la question est de savoir si
on commence à se poser la question à cet
affreux on arrive à 130 on arrive à 140
et autres bon je vous rappelle que les
déficits américains au sortir de la
seconde guerre mondiale lorsque on était
dans une situation certes n'ai pas
comparé à parce qu'il ya pas de
destruction mais quand même on prend une
situation particulière avait dépassé les
23 24 % les déficits américains
est on est on sait pas dit ouh la la
qu'est-ce qui se passe on a fait un
effort de guerre à fournir point c'est
tout ce qu'il fallait faire là
aujourd'hui si on commence à être petit
bras on va dire ah non au ca commence à
reprendre sur le chômage partiel en
vêtements généreux on va commencer à
faire du bricolage et on va pas être
dans un soutien massif et bien les
effets de la crise vont se multiplier
et n'oublions pas que le fondement d'une
politique économique c'est être une
garantie d'activité voilà c'est une
garantie d'activité et pour moi c'est ça
qui est essentiel il ne pas confondre
les objectifs intermédiaires les
objectifs finaux les objectifs
intermédiaires
c'est le déficit et là j'ai les
objectifs finaux c'est la croissance et
l'emploi
donc il faut pas que les objectifs
intermédiaires mangent les objectifs
finaux et donc le gouvernement doit
avoir comme boussole uniquement la
croissance et l'emploi et aussi penser
au futur c'est à dire pas forcément
rester dans le même type d'économie
préparer cette transition énergétique
nécessaire lutter contre les inégalités
et la donne est un véritable horizon de
projets à cette société et pas
simplement de dire que c'est une bagarre
comptable pour un point de déficit ou
moins déficit ou plus de dette
la vraie question c'est de garantir
l'activité et faire en sorte que notre
économie est bien ne s'effondre pas et
d'autre part que certains actifs ne soit
pas tellement déprécier que des
champions nationaux que des entreprises
importantes et bien soit racheté pour un
boucher du poignet un bouchée de pain
par d'autres fectivement états émergents
pour les gens sans vous êtes d'accord
d'accord sur le fait que qu'on doit
faire en sorte que l'activité économique
reprenne ça c'est clair je ne suis pas
certaine que je suis d'accord sur les
moyens
de toute façon il est vrai que le niveau
de dette en tant que telle n'a pas
franchement d'importance et votre
capacité de remboursement qui est
important donc si vous êtes si vous
faites ddd vous prenez des mesures qui
vous permettent en fait de récupérer de
l'activité économique par la suite
c'est génial c'est pas grave si
aujourd'hui les déficits s'aggravent et
que la dette s'accumule
l'important c'est d'être en capacité de
rembourser donc voila et d ici là où il
peut y avoir des désaccords sur la façon
dont on va fait deux dons dont va se
dérouler cette reprise donc bien
évidemment frédéric sera est clairement
plus en faveur d'une relance de la
demande comme garantie de la reprise
économique et et moi je serai là pour
faire au moins l'opposition
je serais plutôt que du côté de celle
qui favoriserait les conditions d'offre
c'est à dire de faire en sorte que
l'activité économique reparte afin de
pouvoir en effet faire face à une
éventuelle des tsé
c'est ça en fait qui est très important
et c'est pour ça que les pays qui ont
des crises de la dette
c'est évidemment le niveau de la dette
qui est important mais c'est le niveau
de la tête
au regard de ce qu'ils sont capables de
rembourser il faut toujours rappeler que
d'aider les pays comme le japon une
dette énorme et on n'en parle jamais une
dette bien plus supérieur à la grèce qui
pourtant elle a fait faillite fin a fait
défaut avec fracas et et pour qui on se
pose toujours la question de la
soutenabilité de sa dette
donc effectivement là vraiment ce qui
est important c'est d'être clair sur ce
qu'on pense qui est important à mettre
en oeuvre pour faire participer à la
reprise de l'activité économique sachant
qu'on est toujours quand même dans une
incertitude puisque on ne
et là pour le coup l'élite à un peu peut
difficilement éclairer sur ce point
puisque les scientifiques eux mêmes
n'ont pas une vision claire de ce qui va
se dérouler dans les prochains mois mais
est évidemment il faut s'assurer que
tout soit mis en oeuvre pour que les
entreprises et une capacité de rebond en
fait je pense que c'est ça qui est
vraiment fondamental
je pense que là dessus on pourra être
tous les deux assez d'accord c'est à
dire que l'entreprise devra
effectivement pouvoir s'adapter à ce
nouveau contexte il faudra les laisser
s'adapter c'est là où en effet il faut
il faut accentuer la capacité d'agilité
qui est un terme très à la mode en
management mais qui pour le coup
pourrait s'appliquer particulièrement
bien à notre situation puisque dans une
incertitude radicale
comme dans laquelle on est actuellement
puisqu'on n'a pas de certitude sur le
scénario qui va se dérouler il faut
surtout permettre en fait l'adaptation
le plus possible merci tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]